-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
This is it. You're here.
You made it.
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, today, President
Biden unveiled a new Website
called covid.gov
where people can go for masks,
test kits,
vaccines,
and treatment information.
The COVID site's got everything
you need -- tests, masks,
and a list of excuses
to get out of your friend's
destination wedding.
[ Laughter ]
"I know restrictions are lifted,
but, uh, yeah, I don't know."
If you haven't seen the new
COVID site, here it is.
Yeah.
And just to make it
look more trustworthy
for your crazy uncle,
there's a beta version
that looks like this.
-♪ And I'm proud
to be an American ♪
-Ah, I trust that one.
-♪ Where at least I know
I'm free ♪
That's a Website I can trust.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Biden announced
the new COVID Website,
and then he sat down to get
his second booster shot.
-Ooh.
-Right after Biden's doctor said
he needed a boost,
his poll numbers were like,
"Tell me about it."
[ Laughter ]
Biden said
the shot felt wonderful.
Based on the current news,
there's a chance
getting stuck with a needle
really was the best part
of his day.
It actually got
a little awkward.
After he rolled up his sleeve,
Biden said,
"Looks like inflation also
hit these pythons."
[ Laughter ]
[ Smooches ]
Meanwhile, I read
that over in Russia,
Putin's senior advisors
have been giving him
false information about the war
because they're, "too afraid
to tell him the truth."
-Ooh.
-You'd think his advisors
would be more comfortable
telling him the truth.
I mean, they've always seemed
so close.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
Same table.
It's getting crazy.
Today Putin left a meeting like,
"I can't believe
I'm sexiest man alive.
I can't believe I --
This is unbelievable.
Third year in a row."
[ Laughter ]
Here's a wild story.
Republican lawmakers are furious
at fellow Republican
Madison Cawthorn
after he went on a podcast
and said that his colleagues
in Washington
like to have drug-fueled
sex parties.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Of course,
Congressional Republicans
are denying the whole thing.
And many of them
even put out statements.
First, Congressman Kevin
McCarthy said...
Next up, Congressman
Steve Scalise said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Congressman Billy Long said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, some business news.
Amazon has been secretly testing
its drone delivery program.
And this year, they plan
to drop packages from the sky
to more than 1,000 customers.
Yeah.
Pretty soon,
at Amazon headquarters,
they're going to be like,
"Target acquired.
Release the Fruit of the Loom
three-pack right now."
Yeah.
Meanwhile, if you choose
three-day shipping,
the packages fall to Earth
much, much slower.
The drone program
is called Prime Air.
Prime Air.
That actually sounds more like
a fancy bottle of oxygen
they try to sell on
"Shark Tank."
"Hi, Sharks."
I heard about a man in Ohio
who was robbed,
but the thief had
a very interesting approach.
Listen to this.
-The victim told police
he was approached
by a man in a ski mask
holding a pocket knife.
The robber demanded cash
and made the victim
pinky promise
he wouldn't report the robbery
before riding off on a bicycle.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-When the victim handed
over the money,
the thief said,
"Hey, I didn't say 'Simon says'!
Hey!"
Can we see
the getaway vehicle?
Oh, yeah, that makes sense.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
That makes sense.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally,
a mall in New Jersey
has a new vending machine
that you can make a burger
in six minutes.
-Ooh.
-Here it is. Look at this thing.
Yeah.
That's great,
'cause before this,
getting a burger
was so time-consuming.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, how fast
do you need a burger
when you look at McDonald's
and you go,
"I don't have time for that"?
Yeah, but it makes burgers
and doesn't talk.
It's basically your dad
every Fourth of July.
You guys, we have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody.
-♪ The man at hand
that rule the school ♪
♪ And reach and teach the blind
and find a way from A to Z ♪
♪ To reach the most
and boast loud and proud ♪
♪ The gain and vein of a main,
do that thang ♪
♪ When the heat is on,
you feel a fire ♪
♪ From the Empire on a more
higher level of depth ♪
♪ One step for young ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
That's right, what a show!
What a show we have
for you tonight.
He's currently on his new
standup tour
called "The King's Jester."
Hasan Minhaj is here tonight.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Funny, funny, funny dude.
Plus, he's the WWE
Universal Champion,
and you can see him
at "Wrestlemania,"
which begins streaming
Saturday night on Peacock.
Roman Reigns is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's the best.
And we got great music
from Mimi Webb,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fun show.
It's a great show.
We actually had a great show
last night.
Jared Leto was here.
His new Marvel movie "Morbius"
is out this weekend.
I'm always blown away
by how he's able
to disappear into his roles.
Really, it's amazing.
Actually, something happened
amazing last night
when Jared was here,
right before the show.
-Really?
-Yeah, check this out.
Hey, Jared.
I'm so excited you're on
the show tonight.
I just wanted to --
Oh. Sorry.
I thought this was Jared's room.
-It is.
-What do you mean?
-Ahh.
-What?
-I was just in character.
-That's incredible.
You really disappear
into your roles.
I was going to say,
I just saw "Morbius,"
and I barely recognized you
at first.
-I appreciate that.
I really do.
-Hey, Jimmy.
What's going on?
-Oh, hey, Higgins.
I was just saying hi to Jared.
-Jared?
There's nobody in here with you.
-What do you mean?
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Where'd he go?
-[ Sighs ]
I'm right here.
-A-Again, unrecognizable.
I don't even understand
how you do it.
It's so good.
-I'm just kidding.
It was really me.
-Oh.
-[ Grunts ]
Got you again.
-I can't believe it.
Y-You were Jared
pretending to be Higgins
pretending to be Jared
pretending to be Higgins?
Almost. But -- But no. I --
I'm not Jared.
-Then who are you?
-I'm Jimmy.
-Then that makes me --
-Yep.
-[ Sighs ]
Jared.
-Incredible.
-Not too bad yourself.
-Thank you.
So, wait, where is Higgins?
[ Tariq rapping ]
-My first guest
stars in "Morbius."
Give it up for Jared Leto!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Higgins laughing ]
-You know what?
Let him have it.
Want to grab a bite?
-Thought you'd never ask.
[ Hisses ]
-♪ The jig is up,
the news is out ♪
♪ They've finally found me ♪
♪ The renegade... ♪